hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game between yanni
pomnich and magnus carlson it's from the
world under 14 championship uh that was
uh played in greece uh so this is their
third encounter altogether actually
we've already shown the first encounter
that was from the european under 12
championship if you guys haven't seen
that one it will be the first link in
the description below so maybe you want
to check out that one before going into
this one as this is kind of a prelude to
the world chess championship match that
will uh be played in november this year
uh so this is their third encounter
second one was in the uh i believe uh uh
world under 12 championship and this is
now the world under 14 championship it's
a really tough tough crowd the the
competition is great and you guys will
enjoy this game so nipple with the white
pieces opens with e4 we have c5 by
magnus going for the sicilian defense
it's very interesting is this something
that we will see uh also in the
uh the their 2021 world church
championship match and here nipple goes
for c3 the elephant variation of the
sicilian uh preparing d4 yeah so here d5
by magnus it's a very standard response
when white plays a move like c3 because
the pawn on c3 is preventing the knight
from coming to c3 so you actually don't
mind the e captures on e5 and queen
captures uh white will not have this
extra tempo of um just dislodging the
queen from uh from d5 so d4 by white uh
and now usually black will just play
something like knight f6 knight to c6
but magnus goes for uh pawn to g6 he
wants the fiance to his dark square
bishop uh we have knight to f3 and now
bishop to g7 we have knight to a3 now
as we said the c3 square is not
available but also the knight covers the
c4 square and we can kick away the queen
with bishop to c4 so c captures on d4
and now magnus of course sorry nipple
develops the bishop to c4 and attacks
the queen before recapturing the pawn
here so queen to e4 checked by magnus
and now nipple plays bishop to e3 and
we've already reached a position from
the thumbnail it's quite an interesting
one uh why did nepo do this can magnus
capture this well if he captures this
the problem is there's bishop captures
on f7 and now if of course the uh this
uh d-file is not available to the king
the queen covers both squares so you
have to capture and if knight g5 check
you lose the queen
and if you don't capture you could play
king of fade but you still will have to
capture queen v8 check forces the
capture on f7 now knight g5 check and
again you blunder your queen so uh you
actually can't capture this bishop on e3
so magnus continues with knight to h6
and now defends the f7 uh pawn so it
seems like we're ready to capture this
bishop but nipple again with another
very nice trick knight to b5 now saying
uh okay are you maybe interested in the
bishop now but again if the bishop is
captured then it's just a very nice
check made in two knight c7 check only
move king f8 and queen to d8 will be
checkmate
uh so magnus of course not interested in
that he just castles king side and c
captures and d4 finally nippo wins back
his pawn knights to a6 now and now
taking away the the c7 square from
white's knight and now nipple just goes
back knight to c3 uh we have queen back
to c6 the queen is attacked uh now
attacking the bishop and here we have
queen to b3 and it is now as of move 12
that this position has never been
reached again uh since it was played uh
so knights to f5 bringing the knight
back into the game attacking the bishop
on e3 and now we have castles um uh
castles king side and i just realized i
haven't mentioned that this was played
in 2003
if anyone is interested uh so here queen
to b6 magnus offers a queen trade he
wants to go straight in uh for the end
game as his queen not doing all that
much on c6 the white queen and bishop
doing a lot of damage here along this
diagonal you can't really get the rook
into the game so it makes sense to get
the queens off the board and uh nipple
complies we have queen capture some b6a
captures and now knight to a4 going
after uh magnus's b6 pawn so what do you
play here well magnus starts with knight
to d6 he says uh go after the
uh the the pawn here because uh if you
go after it i'm just going to capture on
c4
and that's it okay you've one upon you
have to capture back and then i just
continue developing but i have the
bishop pair and if you go for knight
captures on a8 that is not a free rook
there i'm just going to play bishop to
f5 attack your knight here and the
knight has no way of entering the game
and if rocate the c1 attacking the
knight we're just going to capture on e3
f captures and root capture 78 and you
will have the bishop pair for a rook
which is of course something no one
would uh
play unless the position really
asks for it you know and if it was like
a necessity so bishop back to b3 and now
knight to b4 very uh active with those
knights but the b6 pawn is now
definitely free for grabs and nepo
captures it so knight captures on b6
attacks the rook rook to a6 and now
knight back to d5 we have a trade here
knight captures the bishop captures and
now bishop to f5 so
nepo is now up upon and where is the
compensation both players he'll still
have the bishop pair and there is this
uh two to one advantage on the on the
queen side so that's something that nepo
is definitely interested in playing for
if he can somehow create a pass pawn so
rook after c1 getting the rook to the
only open file on the board makes sense
and rook to a5 by magnus going after the
bishop here
forcing the bishop to maybe move to b3
which is what was played in the game but
also very interesting here is just rook
c5 uh here nepal could ask magnus what
are you planning with that rook what's
what's the idea behind it because if you
capture then the problem is yes you can
now capture on b2 but after bishop
captures on b2 rook to d1
what do you play here
it's a really really tricky position so
we could play something like e6 but then
we're just going to capture this e6 pawn
the knight is hanging so if you move the
knight will you're gonna lose this pawn
and again we get two pass pawns uh not
one so here you might play something
like e6 but then bishop captures f
captures and c captures and d6 again
nipple with this beautiful past the d6
spawn uh so instead nipple went bishop
back to b3 and now we have bishop to e4
very important you want to keep this
defender here but also put pressure here
on the knight if
nipple allows it we might be interested
in doubling white spawns here but we
don't see it so knight to d2 attacks the
bishop now bishop back to c6 doesn't
allow any rook lifting via rook to c7
so a magnus is saying all right i have
the bishop here you're up upon
prove that this is good for white so
bishop to c2 by nippon now uh you could
also force some trades with knights to
c4 attacking the knight and the rook
here but first we have bishop to c2 and
now rook to d8 now magnus is planning to
put a lot of pressure on this pawn here
it's an isolated pawn so we're attacking
it once we might attack it again with
this rook the bishop is attacking it the
knight can come to f5 or b5 to attack it
so there are many ways for us to go
after that pawn so bishop the d3 and now
rook to d5 adding another attacker and
now knight f3 adding another defender
here
and now what do you play here uh well
rook to h5 this is a very interesting
movie it looks almost as a waiting move
uh other than that i don't see really
the idea behind the rook h5 move if any
of you guys have any uh ideas on why
rook h5 was was played you're more than
welcome to share in the comments so we
can discuss it uh but here we have
bishop to e2 now threatening some nasty
discoveries and magnus just goes back
rook to d5 so it could be a waiting move
just waiting to see what nepal will do
uh but now nepal says i'm not interested
in your waiting moves i'm just going to
play g4 take away the h
the h5 and f5 squares and now you are
forced to come up with some sort of a
plan
and okay you could tag this pawn maybe
we trade for example h3 captures
captures but opening of the h file
doesn't really seem to be suiting anyone
if if anything uh it could be
good for white at some point but uh for
black and not really at the moment so
instead we have knight to b5 now really
putting pressure on that d4 pawn and now
bishop the c for attacking the rook so
carlson moves it to d6 and now knight to
e5 now going after the f7 pawn so you
don't really have time to collect here
on d4 uh and sorry about that let me
just uh
uh do something all right uh so after
this um knight to e5 move we have e6 not
allowing any bishop or knight captures
an f7 and now only now bishop captures
on b5 we eliminate one of the defender
one of the attackers of the d4 pawn uh
another idea here is just uh capturing
the bishop uh because you can't really
capture with the rook then the knight
hangs so you have to capture with the
pawn but this just means that we've
created a beautiful pass pawn here uh
nipple does it in a in a similar way he
first captures on b5 and only after
bishop captures now pushes a4 and now
you can't really go to c6 because of the
capture here white would very happily
trade one twice uh to create this past
pawn so bishop has to go all the way
back and now b4 so now nepo wants to
push his two pawns and then create a
pass pawn this way so both um
maneuvers have uh you know their
advantages but the other one just
creates a pass pawn you know right right
out of the the bat
and here magnus has to figure out on how
to continue this position so he decides
to go for rook captures on d4 he says uh
all right your bishop was very
impressive here i'm gonna sacrifice the
exchange here and this will put a lot of
pressure on your position so bishop
captures rook captures and now the
knight is hanging the b4 pawn is hanging
and of course if the knight moves the g4
pawn is hanging with check so what can
nipple do here well he goes for rook to
c8 now of course the rook capture 78
will come with check so magnus has to
defend this with king to f8 and now rook
to e1 just defending um this knight uh
and asking black what do you want to do
and here if magnus wanted to really
trade down he could just play something
like captures captures rook captures
with uh on g4 with checking if uh uh one
and now it could be a bit too dangerous
to go after the uh this um
pawn here for example if rook captures
on b4 then you might even run into
something like rook to b5 because the
bishop is pinned and you're going to
have to trade rooks here so it'd be very
very dangerous of course if rook
captures on a4 then we play rook capture
some b7 and now after the rook comes
here it's just the dead lost so after
king to f1 you're gonna have to play
something like king to e7 and you will
not have time to
uh recollect those pawns now this is
possible and the black would have uh
black would have a
maybe even a decent game here but after
rook to e1 uh rook captures on b4 magnus
wants to keep chances alive he just
collects another pawn and now h3
defending this pawn here we have rook
captures on a4 grabbing another pawn and
now knight to c4 nepo is now threatening
knight to b6 to win material here and
that would be game over so king the e7
has to be played and now rook to d1
cutting off the king from the entire
d-file
and uh well maybe even going for some
rook lifts knight to d6 again becomes an
option the rook now defends this so you
have to be very careful the real
question is can a bishop the c6 be
played because if it can then it's again
very good for magnus for example bishop
c6 if rook to c7 check king f6 now
knight d6 going after rook captures on
f7 it looks like it's dead lost for
black but there is this g5 move that
keeps black alive for example rook
captures on f7 king to g6 and i've
rooked to e7 going after this pawn
bishop d5 can defend both pawns so it uh
it can be played but it's such a such an
ugly line magnus just goes for a
completely different idea he already
sacrificed one exchange he decides to
sacrifice another one so rook captures
on c4 rook captures on c4 and now bishop
the c6 with the bishop guarding the b7
pawn and now we have this very very rare
endgame you will not find this end game
in any endgame manual or tutorial or
in-game book a bishop pair against a
rook pair so how can you how can you
play this black is up to pawns but rooks
are rooks uh but it's very hard to
you know coordinate those two rooks in
between the two bishops because the
bishops just you know slice the
entire board completely and well can
white actually make progress here so
nipple starts with f4
with f5 by magnus this will allow him to
create a pass pawn he just wants the
capture on g4 and after h captures push
h5 and then we're going to have a pass
pawn regardless of what black white
plays so king f2 now comes f characters
and g4 h captures and h5 now this
ensures a pass pawn for magnus g
captures on h5 g captures on h5 and now
rook to c5 goes after that pawn so h4
and now nipple goes after it with rook
to h5 and now bishop to f6 just guarding
this pawn so well this allows some
chances for black to push for the win it
also allows nepo's rooks to just
infiltrate the position so rook to h7
check king to f8 and now rook to d6 and
now from that position where the rooks
were just completely
out of the reach of the black king now
it looks extremely dangerous and now you
could play bishop d5 to just defend this
pawn and keep an eye on both of these
pawns
magnus first goes for bishop to e4
attacks the rook we have rooked the c7
now again it's very very dangerous but
with the bishop covering the d8 square
it doesn't seem like you have all that
much to worry about so magnus only now
retreats the bishop to d5 now this pawn
is covered this pawn is covered and it
seems like there's nothing to worry
about however there is
much to worry about so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
absolutely crushing move for white while
i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the move
that magnus played in the game which uh
that nipple played in the game which is
king to e3 but there is a much much
faster way on winning the game so really
congratulations to everyone who found
this one and that's just rook to d7 rook
d to d7 uh this gets us control of the
seven track rank uh from the perspective
of this rook and now we are threatening
rook to see it so if you found this you
are really a true master of rook
maneuvering
uh
just uh
impossible to parry this position and if
king to e8 now not allowing this because
king captures we just play rook to h7
again threatening check and then if
bishop blocks uh sorry sorry about those
arrows if bishop blocks just rook h8 to
check and that's it we pick up the
bishop we win the game and now of course
if king to d8 again not allowing this
rook to be lifted now we just play rook
to f7 attack this bishop once the bishop
moves with check you can see that now
this check is possible probably why
nipple first play king to e3 yeah before
starting anything to avoid this check
but it doesn't really do all that much
king e2 and now after king to e8 again
not allowing any
checkmating patterns now rook to c7
again we're threatening rook to c8 and
now once again after king to d8 now we
play f5 and that's it uh now this pawn
is a monster of course the pawn cannot
be captured because this simple check
picks up the bishop and there's really
nothing to to to worry about here
there's just no good way to play this so
you have to find all of these rook
maneuvers and then this uh pawn push
with f5 in the in the actual game king
the e3 was played it doesn't change all
that much it just allows black to defend
a little bit longer so king to e8 now
comes rook to h7 and now bishop to e7
this is uh uh now a little bit different
but again uh it's completely winning so
once again uh feel free to pause the
video and win the game once again for
nipple while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations especially if you
found the first one as well and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course rook captures on d5
you could also start with rook to h8 to
check that's fine but rook captures on
d5 is just a game over on the spot e
captures on d5 was played and now we
have king to d4 and it's now a rook
against the bishop with the rook having
absolutely everything covered you can't
bring the king into the game you can't
push the spawn this pawn will fall it's
on a light square so not much for you to
do here magnus played bishop to d6 not
just f5 and he was in this position on
move 53 that magnus carlson resigned in
the game and an excellent victory for
janjapone issue so this is their third
encounter it's a one draw and two wins
for nipple uh it doesn't make any sense
to continue this because well you could
play b6 but we don't care we just can
play king captures on the e5 and if
bishop to e7 just king e6 there's no
playing this for black it's bishop to d8
to try and keep an eye on the pawn we
play rook h8 to checkmate so you either
get checkmated or you avoid checkmate
and then you lose all the material and
then white simply pushes his pawn and
promotes the queen so either way you're
just gonna lose this so uh very nice
game by both of them very interesting uh
first exchange sacrificed by magnus then
another exchange sacrifice that's was
completely crazy i mean two bishops
against two rooks uh but he uh over
pushed it and then you know those rooks
just found their way uh behind the enemy
lines and that was more than enough for
nipple to win this game uh but if you're
wondering who won uh the uh under 14
world championship it was uh it was not
nipple it was not magnus it was actually
actually sergey galco we've shown a game
between magnus and him a few days ago
maybe even a week ago that that was a
bully game so uh it was actually sergey
jigako who won the tournament followed
by uh maxime vashiela grab maximum
rochester only then magnus carlton in
fourth and nepal in fifth place uh so as
you can see just because you're not uh
on the top today doesn't mean you're not
gonna be tomorrow so something maybe to
take um
from this game
uh so yeah i hope you guys enjoyed that
one and that you are uh ready for for
the world chess championship match it's
still a month a month away but you know
it's uh i i haven't covered any of these
uh previous first encounters between the
two of them so i thought you guys might
enjoy that sort of as a prelude to this
great event uh so yeah once again really
hope you guys enjoyed it i would like to
thank eduardo the american flag iglesias
danny green uh david kimura marshall
farrier and jean-francois bond for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of uh
uh you know everything that's just
happening in the chess world checking up
in your wonderful suggestions and of
course preparing the next big saga which
is still a secret
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day